Casual fans of Wonder Woman may have been
intrigued or confused by the armored outfit
the hero wears in her solo movie. After all,
it's a pretty far cry from the classic look
Lynda Carter sported back in the '70s. But
comic book fans know that Wonder Woman's costume
has been in constant flux for the past 75
years. Why? Here's a look at the untold truth
of Wonder Woman's costume.
The original costume
When Wonder Woman first appeared in All-Star
Comics #8 in 1941, she was already recognizable
as the iconic hero we know today. Inspired
by patriotic drawings of Lady Liberty from
the Sufragette movement and World War I, artist
H. G. Peter and writer William Moulton Marston
came up with a look featuring a gold tiara,
bracelets, red strapless top decorated with
a golden eagle, red boots, and blue culottes
spangled with white stars. Yes, that's right,
it's not a skirt — it's culottes.
So why does Wonder Woman dress like the American
flag if she's not even from America? Because
Wonder Woman's mom, Queen Hippolyta, cleverly
designed the costume to make her daughter
more popular and appealing to Americans. Now
there's a savvy public relations move!
A sanitized post-war version
When Marston died in 1947, the radical feminist
subtext of Wonder Woman died with him, killed
off by new writer Bob Kanigher. Diana soon
embraced traditional gender roles for the
1950s, longing to marry Steve Trevor and settle
down as a housewife. Her costume changed to
reflect her new values: her boots were replaced
with ballet slippers, her hair was pulled
back in a more conservative 'do, and her swimsuit
like costume became more demure, carefully
covering her cleavage and upper thighs.
No costume, just fashion
In the late 1960s, Wonder Woman underwent
a drastic makeover, losing her superpowers
and her star-spangled costume to become a
globe-trotting action hero in the mold of
Emma Peel, the popular character played on
the British TV series The Avengers. Not only
was the new, mod Diana a fashion plate in
her own right, modeling a line of sleek jumpsuits
befitting an international adventurer, she
even opened a fashion boutique to help other
women find their own inner Wonder Woman.
The new look Wonder Woman ended in 1972 when
Gloria Steinem featured Wonder Woman on the
cover of the first issue of Ms. Magazine and
successfully pressured DC Comics into returning
her to her superpowered roots.
A new logo
Diana's costume received an important update
in 1982. DC President Jenette Kahn wanted
to give Wonder Woman a distinctive logo that
could be used for trademark and licensing
purposes. That eagle on her chest was nice
and patriotic, but it was also very generic,
unlike the logos for heroes like Superman
and Batman. Graphic designer Milton Glaser
created a new double-W logo with wings. In
the comics, Diana is given this new design
by members of a real-world charity organization
called the Wonder Woman Foundation, and decides
to wear it to help raise awareness of social
issues facing women around the world. Versions
of this logo have been in use ever since.
A different Diana
After the DC Universe was rebooted in the
Crisis on Infinite Earths crossover, writer/artist
George Pérez was brought in to relaunch Wonder
Woman in 1987. Though he left the costume
mostly the same, he gave it a new background
to explain exactly why it looks like an American
flag. In this new origin story, Steve Trevor's
mother Diana crashed her plane on the hidden
island of Themyscira in the 1940s and died
helping the Amazons defeat a mystical threat
from the underworld. To honor her legacy,
Queen Hippolyta named her daughter after Diana
Trevor, and designed a ceremonial suit of
armor based on the Women in the Air Force
patches on Trevor's flight jacket. That armor
would eventually become the basis for the
outfit we know and love from the movies.
Going full '90s
In the 1990s, the big trend in the comics
was replacing old heroes with newcomers. For
Diana, that meant she lost the title of Wonder
Woman to another Amazon named Artemis. Diana
kept up the good fight, of course, but she
did it wearing biker shorts, a strappy bikini
top, a bolero jacket, and no less than three
belts. She even got a shorter haircut with
bangs to complete the extreme aesthetic. Naturally,
she got her title and the costume that goes
with it back after a few months, and her hair
even grew back out as soon as she put it on.
Thank the gods!
Hippolyta's sword
A few years later, Diana again stopped being
Wonder Woman and her lookalike mother Hippolyta
took her place. Hippolyta's Wonder Woman costume
brought back the classic eagle, but made it
more like armor than a simple insignia. Meanwhile,
the W logo moved to her belt. She also wore
a skirt and carried a sword and shield instead
of a lasso. Though Hippolyta's time as Wonder
Woman has largely been forgotten, the design
changes made by artist John Byrne have had
a lasting impact on Wonder Woman's look.
Donna's armor
The Infinite Crisis crossover shook up the
DC Universe in 2006 — not least with another
new Wonder Woman in the form of Donna Troy,
Diana's adopted sister of sorts, and the hero
formerly known as Wonder Girl. As the star
of a relaunched Wonder Woman series written
by Allan Heinberg with art by Terry and Rachel
Dodson, Donna wore a fully armored costume
with a gladiator skirt and a sword on her
belt.
Diana's pants
After dressing Wonder Woman in her classic
outfit for a number of years, DC Comics decided
to go totally off the rails in 2010 and revamped
her outfit to include a black leather jacket,
a choker, and some yoga pants thrown in for
good measure. While some fans were happy to
see her wearing a more practical outfit instead
of a star-spangled swimsuit, the unfortunate
'90s vibe created by artist Jim Lee brought
back too many traumatic memories. It didn't
end up mattering much either way, though,
because DC changed her look yet again just
a year later.
Armored in silver
In 2011, DC continuity was completely rebooted,
and their entire line was relaunched with
52 new #1 issues. Diana's new look was once
again designed by Jim Lee, but this time it
hewed closer to the original look, albeit
with some significant alterations. All traces
of yellow and gold in the costume were replaced
with silver instead, and the red on her top
was textured to make it look more like armor
than fabric. This costume also included a
sword — which has been standard for all
Wonder Woman costumes since — and for some
reason another choker.
The movie look
We caught our first glimpse of Gal Gadot as
Wonder Woman in July of 2014, in a promo image
for Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice, but
since then fans have had plenty of opportunity
to see the new cinematic look in action.
The top is dark red and armored, while the
bottom is a blue gladiator skirt. She has
the W logo on her belt, like Hippolyta's costume,
although there's another W layered into the
eagle design on her chest. Her tiara points
down rather than up as it traditionally has
in the comics. And of course, she carries
a sword and a shield, in addition to the magic
lasso. It all adds up to one of the most instantly
iconic looks in Wonder Woman — and superhero
— history.
In 2016, DC once again rebooted their line
of comics, introducing another new costume
for Wonder Woman. This time, however, artist
Tony Daniel took the popular look from the
movies and used it as the basis for the design,
ensuring that fans of both the comics and
the films won't be confused — or disappointed.
No matter what she's wearing, one thing is
for sure: she's a wonder, that Wonder Woman...
Thanks for watching! Click the Looper icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel. Plus
check out all this cool stuff we know you'll
love, too!